Salut !
Aujourd'hui,
on va s'intéresser au cerveau...
- Fabien.
- Oui ?
- Alors, c'est parce que
t'es très grand là.
Voilà, alors un peu...
- Là c'est mieux là ?
- Voilà !
Salut, aujourd'hui
on va s'intéresser au cerveau
et à ses capacités incroyables.
C'est ce qui me plaît le plus,
et je crois que c'est
ce qui vous plaît aussi.
Vous vous demandez pourquoi
certaines personnes
sont des génies
et d'autres ne le sont pas ?
Moi je me le demande
régulièrement, tu vois.
- Ah bon ?
- Ouais.
- Ah ça alors !
- comment tu fais
pour être aussi génial Loïc ?
-  Merci !
Et vrai, est-ce que
c'est de la chance
ou est-ce que
c'est de l'apprentissage ?
Mais surtout,
est-ce que vous pouvez,
vous aussi le devenir
du jour au lendemain ?
Est-ce qu'on peut
déclencher ça ?
La réponse, c'est un oui !
Et en faisant mes recherches,
j'ai enfin trouvé la méthode
pour devenir un génie.
Et en vrai c'est pas difficile.
Loïc, générique.
- Luluoui ?
Si vous avez toujours rêvé
de devenir un génie,
c'est maintenant ou jamais.
Vous avez juste besoin
d'un truc, c'est tout bête.
C'est un gros coup sur la tête,
avec un petit traumatisme crânien
pour débloquer le savant
qui est en vous.
Voilà, voilà.
- Okay, tu peux
nous montrer s'il te plait ?
Un petit exemple
sur toi, ta personne ?
- Non parce que moi,
je dois faire la vidéo avec eux.
Du coup tu veux pas toi,
être mon cobaye plutôt ?
- Ah oui en fait moi, je dois cadrer,
ensuite il y a le montage, donc c'est..
- Ouais.
En même temps,
t'as pas tord Loïc,
parce que la proportion
des personnes
qui développent des facultés
exceptionnelles après une blessure
est inférieure à un pour mille.
En fait c'est pas beaucoup,
c'est plutôt risqué.
Mais quand ça arrive on appelle ça
le syndrome du savant acquis,
qui permet d'avoir
des idées de génie
et des compétences
vraiment hallucinantes.
- Le savon à qui ?
- Du savon à qui ?
- C'est pas ce que t'as dit ?
Du savon à qui, le savant acquis !
- Ah okay !
- Le savant acquis,
mais peut-être j'articule mal des fois.
C'est le savant acquis.
- C'est à qui ?
- Je sais pas,
il est à qui ce savon alors ?
Donc je disais le syndrome
du savant acquis,
qui permet d'avoir
des idées de génie
et des compétences
vraiment dingues.
- Genre des compétences un peu oufs
que personne ne peut avoir ?
- Exact.
- Genre imaginons, un truc impossible
c'est genre tu dépenses de l'argent.
- Ouais.
- Okay ?
Mais en même temps que
tu dépenses de l'argent, t'en gagnes !
- Ouais.
- ça c'est impossible !
- C'est pas complètement
impossible ça.
ça existe déjà Loïc.
Et vraiment, c'est le partenariat
d'aujourd'hui qui s'appelle iGraal
et là il n'y a pas besoin
d'avoir un cerveau spécial
pour comprendre ce que c'est,
pour s'en servir
tout le temps non plus.
Je vous explique !
iGraal, c'est un site, une appli,
une extension gratuite
qui permet d'avoir un cash back
chez plus de 1700 vendeurs.
Alors comment c'est possible,
c'est quoi un cash back ?
C'est très simple, c'est quand
vous dépensez de l'argent,
vous avez un retour après
dans une cagnotte, chez iGraal.
Ils vont remettre de l'argent
en fonction de votre dépense.
C'est ça un cash back.
Et ça comment c'est possible,
vous allez me dire ?
Eh bien parce que iGraal
touche une commission
à chaque fois qu'il y a une vente
chez l'un de ces marchands.
Et vous reverse du coup,
une partie de la commission
sur votre cagnotte iGraal.
C'est comme ça que ça fonctionne.
Du coup dès que vous avez
20 euros dans votre cagnotte,
vous pouvez demander
un virement bancaire,
Paypal ou un chèque cadeau.
Je vous montre,
c'est pas compliqué.
Je vais aller regarder
sur le site de Uculture,
pour voir les cadeaux de Noël
que je vais faire.
Potentiellement
mes propres livres,
parce que mes livres
sont sur Uculture,
donc c'est quand même
très pratique pour offrir mes livres.
A côté du lien,
on voit déjà le picto
qui montre que iGraal a détecté
que c'était un site partenaire,
ça c'est super pratique.
Et si je clique dessus,
l'extension s'active en haut
et je vois qu'il y a 5 %
de cash back en ce moment,
j'ai plus qu'à l'activer.
Et ce qui est cool, c'est que
le cash back fonctionne aussi
avec les codes promos
et les soldes.
C'est pas le cash back
ou le code promo,
tout fonctionne ensemble.
D'ailleurs des fois,
il y a des codes promos
qui sont proposés directement
en haut, par iGraal.
Autre exemple
avec le kiosque mag,
vous pouvez avoir jusqu'à
4 euros de cash back
si vous voulez vous abonner
à un magasine par exemple,
Ou à quelque chose comme ça.
Vous pouvez aussi
passer par le site d'iGraal,
pour affiner votre recherche
directement par catégorie.
Là je vois qu'il y a du cash back
et des codes promos chez Kobo,
donc je vais aller prendre
mes e-books là bas.
Si iGraal vous intéresse
vous avez un cadeau en plus,
si vous passez par mon lien,
ils vous offrent 10 euros
dans votre cagnotte
en cadeau de bienvenue.
Au lieu de 3 euros,
qu'ils offrent en temps normal
en cadeau de bienvenue.
Le lien est tout en haut
de la barre d'infos,
vous avez juste à cliquer dessus
pour découvrir un peu plus,
ou télécharger l'extension
par exemple,
Voilà, merci iGraal.
Maintenant que vous savez
faire du cash back,
revenons à notre syndrome
du savant acquis.
Suite à un traumatisme crânien,
un accident vasculaire cérébral
ou une maladie qui touche
le système nerveux central.
Le cerveau peut se mettre à
développer des dons artistiques
ou intellectuels,
un peu hors du commun.
Berit Brogard, une neuroscientifique
de l'université du Missouri,
a expliqué que lors d'un choc,
des cellules du cerveau peuvent mourir.
Et donc libérer une énorme
quantité de neurotransmetteurs.
Les substances chimiques
que ça libère
sont susceptibles d'activer
des zones cérébrales, en particulier,
mais qui jusqu'à présent étaient
complètement inactifs dans le cerveau.
Mais il faut savoir qu'il existe
le syndrome du savant, du savant.
Et le syndrome
du savant acquis.
Et c'est très important
de distinguer les deux,
parce que c'est pas
la même chose.
- Bah oui !
- Logique.
Dans le cas
du syndrome du savant.
La personne, elle naît avec
un trouble du développement.
Un autisme par exemple,
tout en ayant des capacités un peu
extraordinaires pour nous autres.
C'est le cas de Kim Peek,
l'homme qui a inspiré
le personnage du film Rain man.
Je sais pas si vous l'avez vu,
c'est un excellent film.
Il est né autiste, il a développé
une mémoire exceptionnelle
et des facultés de calcul mental
qui étaient juste dingues.
Mais à côté de ça,
il était pas capable
par exemple d'appréhender
le prix d'un pain au chocolat.
Donc il y a des choses un peu folles
qu'il était capable de faire.
Et en même temps,
il y a des choses où
socialement parlant, il était inadapté.
Pour la petite anecdote,
à 7 ans il a mémorisé
toutes les pièces
du répertoire de Shakespeare
dans les moindres détails.
39 pièces au total quand même.
Et le gars,
c'est une machine de guerre.
Lorsqu'il allait voir des
représentations d'un Shakespeare.
Il se levait pendant le spectacle
pour dire aux acteurs, aux musicien :
"Attendez, c'est parce que
le trombone,
il est à deux mesures trop rapides,
donc si on pouvait
attendre le trombone".
Ou "Non, parce que là en fait,
il y avait une virgule
que vous n'avez pas respecté".
Donc ça devait être très relou
pour les artistes,
mais en vrai c'est hyper fascinant.
Et comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure,
dans le cas du syndrome
du savant acquis.
C'est donc acquis
à un moment donné de la vie
de manière
complètement inattendue.
Lors d'un choc
ou d'une maladie.
Le psychiatre Darold Treffert...
- Il préfère quoi ?
Darold prèfère.
- Non, Treffert.
- Très près.
- Très magnésium, très fer.
- Ah !
Darold Treffert, un expert reconnu
du syndrome du savant
a répertorié 330 savants
dans le monde.
300 seraient nés comme ça.
Et les 30 autres seraient
devenus comme ça,
au cours de leur vie
à cause d'un traumatisme.
30 dans le monde,
ça fait quand même
un truc extrêmement rare.
En général, lorsque vous faites
un traumatisme crânien,
il y a de fortes chances que vous ayez
uniquement des séquelles graves.
Style hémorragies,
pertes de mémoire etc.
Donc n'essayez pas
de le faire volontairement quoi.
En premier, on s'intéresse
à Jason Padgett,
un américain de 50 ans.
Qui lui, n'a eu aucun souci.
Le 13 septembre 2002,
alors qu'il sortait d'un bar karaoké,
il a été brutalement agressé
dans la rue par deux hommes
qui l'ont notamment
frappé à l'arrière de la tête.
On lui a diagnostiqué
une commotion cérébrale très sévère.
Le matin, donc du lendemain,
Jason remarque qu'il ne voit plus
les choses de la même manière,
mais c'est un peu dingue.
Alors que l'eau
coulait dans son bain,
il a remarqué que
des lignes s'échappaient perpi...
Perpen...
- Perpignan !
Perpendiculairement à l'eau.
Non mais en vrai,
il regardait l'eau qui s'écoulait
et voyait des lignes
perpendiculaires à l'eau.
C'était limite, il voyait
la formule mathématique dedans.
"Au début, j'étais effrayé et inquiet
mais après c'était si beau
que je suis resté là
dans mes pantoufles à regarder".
Alors c'est un peu bizarre,
je vous l'accorde.
Mais c'est fascinant.
Jason se met
à dessiner ce qu'il voit.
Des fractales, alors qu'il n'était
absolument pas capable de faire ça
avant l'altercation
qui lui a causé ce choc derrière.
- Et excuse moi, les fractales ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est les fractales ?
- Eh bien écoutez Lolo,
je vais vous dire.
ça fait longtemps
qu'il n'était pas venu celui là.
Les fractales c'est quoi ?
Les fractales, ce sont des figures
géométriques hyper complexes.
Et quand on les dessine
ça donne ça.
Et on peut zoomer
de manière un peu infinie,
enfin complètement infinie,
je sais pas pourquoi je dis un peu,
à l'intérieur.
Et cet ancien vendeur de meubles
reconverti en mathématicien
passionné de dessin,
vend aujourd'hui des œuvres
à base de fractales,
à plusieurs milliers de dollars.
Berit Brogaard,
la neuroscientifique
dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure début de la vidéo.
A scanné le cerveau
de Jason grâce à une IRM.
Et elle lui a montré des centaines
d'équations vraie ou fausses.
Elle lui faisait voir
les équations sur un papier
et en même temps avec l'IRM,
elle regardait un peu
ce qui se passait
dans la tête de Jason.
Elle a observé son cerveau,
pour voir quelles étaient les parties
qui s'activaient surtout.
Elle a constaté que des lésions
se trouvaient au niveau
du cortex visuel
et qu'une activation anormale
était également constatée
au niveau du cortex pariétal.
Oui mais le cortex pariétal,
c'est une zone qui est très connue
pour être associée
aux mathématiques
et à la planification des actions.
En gros, le cortex visuel travaille
avec la partie du cerveau
qui fait des mathématiques.
Tout s'explique !
Berit lui explique que son choc,
a aussi provoqué
une forme de synesthésie.
Tu sais ce que c'est Loïc,
une synesthésie ?
- Ouais, c'est quand les plantes
reçoivent de la lumière...
- Pas du tout.
- après ça leur permet de grandir.
- Oui, c'est la photosynthèse.
- Ah oui, j'avais le "Y"
dedans qui était bon.
- Loïc, j'ai fait une vidéo
en 2016 sur la synesthésie.
- J'étais pas né.
- ça me fait du mal
que tu l'aies pas regardée.
T'étais pas abonné en 2016 ?
- Je parlais pas français.
- T'étais pas abonné.
Tu fais pas partie des 1000 premiers
abonnés de ma chaine ?
- Non.
Je suis même pas
abonné maintenant.
- C'est peut-être le cas
de certains d'entre vous,
donc n'hésitez pas,
abonnez vous maintenant
et activez la cloche, comme ça
vous raterez aucune vidéo.
La synesthésie, c'est un trouble
de la perception des sensations.
En gros, certains verront par exemple
des couleurs en jouant de la musique.
Tandis que Jason lui, il voyait
des modèles mathématiques
et des motifs géométriques
dans son champ de vision.
Il existe un peu plus de 150 formes
de synesthésie différentes.
La plus courante par exemple,
c'est les personnes qui associent
un jour de la semaine à une couleur.
Mais pas d'une manière volontaire.
Ils n'ont pas décidé que le mardi
serait bleu par exemple.
C'est depuis toujours,
quand ils entendent mardi,
pour eux c'est bleu.
Quand Jason voit les feuilles
des arbres devant sa fenêtre.
ça représente pour lui,
la preuve de l'existence
du théorème de Pythagore, c'est fou.
Quand il voit un arc en ciel
qui rebondit sur sa voiture,
ça lui prouve la puissance de pi.
En gros, tout ce qui se trouve autour
de lui a un sens mathématique.
- Et du coup, le mec c'est "bingo",
aucune séquelle...
- Bingo !
- Bingo.
- Du coup, oui, bingo.
Alors ça n'était pas bingo, désolé.
Il n'a pas touché le jackpot,
il a quand même des séquelles.
Malheureusement,
devenir un génie,
ça peut aussi
rendre un peu psychorigide.
Puisque le traumatisme
crânien de Jason,
lui a aussi provoqué beaucoup
de tocs de propreté.
Et une grosse anxiété sociale.
Il est littéralement obsédé
par les microbes,
il faut savoir
qu'il se lave les mains
jusqu'à ce qu'elles deviennent
complètement rouges.
Et qu'il ne peut plus
faire de câlins à sa fille,
sans qu'elle ne se soit lavé les mains
plusieurs fois juste avant.
ça lui arrive aussi de clouer
des couvertures sur ses fenêtres
et de refuser
toute visite de l'extérieur.
Bref, vous avez compris
c'est pas forcément facile à vivre.
On va voir maintenant
ce qu'il en est pour Derek Amato,
un américain de 53 ans.
Le 27 octobre 2006,
ce qui devait être un bon moment,
a tourné à la catastrophe pour Derek.
Derek se tenait
au bord d'une piscine,
il a crié à son pote
de lui lancer un ballon.
Et en se jetant dans les airs pour
le rattraper et tomber dans la piscine,
il est tombé dans la partie qui est
pas du tout profonde de la piscine.
Où il s'est violemment
cogné la tête contre le béton.
Il a été emmené aux urgences,
où les médecins
lui ont diagnostiqué
une grave commotion cérébrale.
Les médecins l'ont renvoyé chez lui
pour qu'il puisse se reposer.
Et les séquelles sont assez lourdes,
puisqu'il a perdu 35% de son audition,
il a des pertes de mémoire,
des maux de tête
à répétition, forcément.
Et pleins de choses comme ça,
mais il s'attendait sûrement pas
à des conséquences positives.
Une fois qu'il s'est remis
de tous ces événements.
Quelques jours plus tard,
il se rend chez un pote à lui,
chez qui il est étonnamment
attiré par un piano.
Il pose ses mains
sur le clavier du piano,
il se met à jouer
comme un virtuose.
Il faut savoir que Derek
n'a jamais joué de piano de sa vie,
il n'a jamais appris la technique.
Et pourtant il se met à jouer
de manière instinctive.
En rentrant de chez son pote,
Derek cherche sur internet
des explications un peu
à ce qui se passe.
Il remarque alors que
d'autres personnes ont vécu
la même chose que lui,
mais dans d'autres circonstances.
Il a fini par trouver le contact
du psychiatre Darold Treffert.
Et Derek le contacte
et se fait diagnostiquer
le syndrome du savant acquis.
Et là on lui explique,
que son accident aurait conduit à
une réorganisation de ses neurones,
qui lui permettraient à priori
d'accéder à des zones
qui étaient jusque là inutilisées.
Il faut savoir
qu'avant son accident,
Derek savait jouer
quelques accords à la guitare,
mais c'est tout, rien de plus.
Il avait probablement
une pré-disposition à la musique,
qui a resurgi suite à cet accident.
Et dans sa compréhension
de comment fonctionnait un piano,
plus sa petite connaissance,
toute petite de la guitare.
Tout s'est associé.
Et depuis il sait jouer, c'est fou !
Pour le psychiatre
Docteur Dan Angie,
il y avait une chance sur cent millions
de débloquer cette capacité de génie.
Et tout comme Jason Padgett,
il est aussi atteint de synesthésie,
puisqu'il voit la musique
avec des carrés noirs et blancs,
qui tournent autour de sa tête.
C'est à peu près
comme ça qu'il l'explique.
De là, il en traduit des notes
qui lui permettent de composer,
de jouer de manière instantanée.
Il dit :
"Ce sont mes mains
qui font le travail,
elles exécutent uniquement
ce qu'ordonne mon esprit".
Et on peut voir dans un documentaire
qui lui a été consacré, "Humans limits",
avec quelle facilité,
fluidité il joue du piano
et ce depuis le premier jour.
Pour lui, c'est comme
si le fantôme de Beethoven
avait sauté dans son corps.
En mode vas-y, je m'y mets.
Vous dites quoi, je n'entends pas,
parce que je suis Beethoven.
Docteur Indre Viskontas...
Docteur Indre Viskontas,
au conservatoire de San Francisco,
est impressionnée par la fluidité
de ses mouvements,
alors que la majorité des musiciens
galèrent avec ça pendant des mois,
voire des années.
Chez Derek,
c'est apparu en une nuit !
Le revers de tout ça,
c'est qu'il est régulièrement pris
de maux de tête hyper violents,
pertes de mémoire et une sensibilité
à la lumière et aux sons.
Mais ça ne l'empêche pas
de vivre une vie normale
et de dire que
cet accident selon lui,
est la meilleure chose
qui lui soit arrivée.
Anecdote finale, aujourd'hui
il sait jouer plus de huit instruments,
il s'est d'ailleurs tatoué des notes
de musique sur les bras.
Est-ce qu'on pourrait dire,
qu'il a la musique
dans la peau, du coup ?
Parce qu'il a les notes sur les bras.
Non mais c'est une expression.
Imagine, non mais...
Le dernier génie dont
je vous parle aujourd'hui,
s'appelle Alonso Clemons.
C'est un américain encore,
de 62 ans.
Après avoir été blessé à la tête,
lorsqu'il était enfant,
on a pas trop
de détails sur l'accident.
Alonso développe
un don incroyable.
Alors qu'il était à l'école tranquille,
fond de classe, pénard, chill.
Il commence à réaliser
des petites sculptures d'animaux
grâce à de la pâte
à modeler en argile.
Il pouvait faire ça
pendant des heures.
On pouvait dire,
d'ailleurs Loïc, qu'il était agile...
Agile...
- Je crois qu'on avait la même idée
mais c'est pas sorti pareil.
- Mais s'il s'était appelé Gilles,
là c'était Gilles,
il était agile avec de l'argile.
- J'ilargie l'argile.
- Et si l'argile était jaune,
Gilles était agile
avec de l'argile et jaune.
Je sais pas si elle était bien.
Votez entre
1 et B en commentaire.
Alors forcément,
ses profs qui le voyaient
faire des petites sculptures,
au lieu d'écouter,
ils n'aimaient pas trop ça,
ça leur plaisait pas.
Donc il a pris du retard
dans l'apprentissage, ça c'est vrai.
L'école lui retire toute l'argile.
Mais Alonso
ne se laisse pas abattre
et se met à prendre
des morceaux de goudron souple,
qu'on trouve parfois sur la route.
Vous savez
des bouts de goudron,
quand il fait chaud
ils sont un peu manipulables.
Il continue à faire des sculptures.
Il était déterminé de ouf,
effectivement.
Et dans sa chambre, il continuait
à sculpter des animaux en 3D.
Mais de manière
très précise et très rapide.
Et juste à partir d'une image
ou d'une observation dans un zoo,
d'un animal pendant
quelques minutes.
Il a continué à faire
ses sculptures dans l'ombre,
sans vraiment en parler
autour de lui,
jusqu'en 1981
où le syndrome du savant
a été mis en lumière
par le film Rain Man.
Dont vous ai parlé
au début de la vidéo.
Un film qui met en scène un homme
doté d'une mémoire incroyable.
On s'intéresse de plus en plus
aux capacités d'Alonso,
qui est reconnu
comme étant un savant.
Un savant acquis,
et qui après apparaît
dans certaines émissions télé,
qui ont sculpté sa notoriété.
- Par rapport au fait...
- Oui, Lolo !
En 1986, il a tenu sa première
exposition dans le colorado.
Et certaines de ses œuvres
se sont vendues
quand même
jusqu'à 45 000 dollars.
Il faut savoir que comme
son accident est arrivé très jeune,
ça a malheureusement
entraîné des retards,
donc dans son développement.
Et des choses
de la vie quotidienne
qu'il ne parvient
à faire que très difficilement,
comme faire ses lacets
ou manger correctement tout seul.
- Ouais mais du coup,
il y a moyen de devenir un génie,
Mais sans le coup sur la tête
parce que avec toutes les...
J'aime bien manger tout seul.
Excellente question de lolo.com
Vous vous doutez
que ce genre de cas,
attirait la curiosité de toute
la communauté scientifique,
qui a réalisé des tests
en se demandant
si on pouvait débloquer
des compétences extraordinaires,
sans devoir se prendre
un coup sur la tête
et sans les risques
que ça comporte.
Est-ce qu'il y a du génie
qui sommeille en chacun de nous
et qu'on pourrait activer ?
Et pour répondre
à cette question,
les scientifiques ont fait
des expérimentations réversibles
sur des volontaires sains.
Et ils ont réussi à activer
des zones dites dormantes.
Ce qui a révélé des aptitudes,
parfois insoupçonnées
chez certaines personnes.
Un des tests a été réalisé
par le scientifique
Allan Snyder ou Snyder.
Il a distribué un puzzle
géométrique à des volontaires,
mais qui était
assez difficile à réaliser.
L'objectif pour les participants,
relier neuf points
alignés trois par trois,
en utilisant
seulement quatre traits.
Aujourd'hui,
cette énigme est connue,
parce qu'il faut pas repasser
par un des traits qu'on a déjà fait,
il faut pas lever le stylo.
Je l'ai vraiment
d'ailleurs fait sur TikTok.
Mon TikTok qui est juste là.
Et comme vous le voyez, pour
résoudre ce puzzle en neuf points.
Il faut sortir du carré préformé
et dans notre conception,
on imagine pas forcément
le fait de sortir du cadre.
Allan Snyder explique que
notre cerveau est équipé pour prédire.
Ce qui nous sert à fonctionner
rapidement dans ce monde.
Mais qui complexifie
le fait de sortir du cadre.
Au final sur les 28 volontaires,
aucun n'a réussi à réaliser
cette énigme là, à la résoudre.
Et Snyder a ensuite utilisé la stimulation
magnétique transcrânienne.
ça calme un peu,
c'est un peu barbare dit comme ça,
mais en vrai, c'est sans risque.
C'est des électrodes
qui sont posées sur le crâne
et qui envoient
un faible courant électrique.
Les participants
ont été sous stimulation.
Et ensuite 40% d'entre eux,
qui ont reçu une stimulation
ont réussi l'énigme.
Et tous ceux qui avaient reçu
une stimulation placebo,
c'est à dire penser à  en recevoir une,
mais ils n'ont rien reçu.
N'ont pas réussi
à décoder le puzzle.
Donc à ce jour,
il n'y a pas de solution
pour hacker notre cerveau
et débloquer des capacités
hors normes sur le long terme.
C'est resté pour l'instant
en phase de test.
S'il n'y a pas d'autres
solutions pour l'instant...
- Ah non !
- Non, non en vrai...
- Ah bah voilà !
Ah le génie !
- Non mais c'est pour toi.
- C'est quoi pour moi ?
Non, non !
- C'est pour toi !
Bon en vrai, ne faites pas ça,
ne faites jamais ça
c'est beaucoup trop dangereux.
J'espère que cette vidéo
par contre, elle vous a plu.
Si ce sujet vous intéresse,
je pourrais aborder les autres
histoires de génies par accident
dans mes fun facts
sur Instagram ou sur TikTok,
vous avez les comptes ici.
Voilà.
Un grand merci à iGraal
pour ce partenariat,
oubliez pas que vous avez 10 euros
en cadeau de bienvenue chez eux
directement dans votre cagnotte,
si vous passez par mon lien
qui est dans la description.
Au lieu des 3 euros
que vous avez en temps habituel.
Et si vous ne me connaissez pas,
je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard,
oubliez pas de vous abonner
à cette chaîne YouTube, c'est gratuit.
Activez la cloche pour ne pas
rater les prochaines vidéos
Ici je vous mets une vidéo sur la loi
de Benford, c'est un peu fou.
Ici, une vidéo sur des expériences
un peu stylées
qui ont été faites sur le cerveau.
Prenez bien soin de vous,
à très bientôt !
Ciao !